in dakar's affluent neighborhood
this is what is left of a french
supermarket following
another night of riots i'm lost for
words
i have tears in my eyes laments this
cashier as she watches people
including young children take away what
they can
a bag of pasta for babakar endure an
unemployed carpenter who in the looting
saw an opportunity to find
a meal for his family tonight it's not
just about shooting frisanko
we the youth are suffering we are
jobless
countless people have lost their jobs we
need a little something to get by and
feed our families
protesters set the supermarket on fire
following days of nationwide
demonstrations
it all started after the detention of
opposition leader usmansanko last
wednesday
he's accused of rape inciting an
unauthorized protest
and public insurrection but his
supporters say these charges are
politically motivated
describes himself as the
anti-establishment
uh politician he's been very critical of
the relationship of
big corporations with the state and the
government specifically
the president himself accusing him of
corruption
the government wants to see an end to
the violence with the interior ministry
warning looters they will face arrest
several local tv stations have been
taken off air for
inciting violence while journalists
perceived as supporting the government
have come under attack
the government calls on all the nation
citizens and forces for calm and
serenity
while internet monitor net blocks says
social media messaging apps are being
restricted
supporters of sanko civil society
activists
and the opposition have joined forces
taking the protest
both to the streets and online with the
hashtag
free senegal we want to defend our
democracy because we are really
outraged to see how our government
and its allies are really violating the
rights of
the senegalese people our young people
have been organizing fighting in the
streets
standing up to say enough is enough
they believe people are looting because
they're hungry
and are calling for more peaceful
demonstrations across the country
starting monday in what appears to be
not the end
but the beginning of a movement nicholas
hawk al jazeera dakar